si je vous parle du lait à 2 à 2 vous
allez peut-être penser r2d2 guerre des
étoiles
on n'est pas exactement dans la
science-fiction ici et pourtant le lait
à 2 à 2 pourrait être l'aide à venir
parce qu'ils seraient potentiellement
plus facile à digérer que les réguliers
c'est en tout cas ce que certains
producteurs laitiers croit puisqu'ils
ont entrepris de modifier la génétique
de leur troupeau pour en produire
[Musique]
caroline pelletier productrice laitière
à saint-armand en montérégie depuis 20
ans
elle n'est pas son premier village à
preuve cette naissance est clair lors de
notre passage
quelques secondes tout était terminé
[Musique]
les petites génisses se porte bien
elle ira grossir un troupeau de 60
vaches 2 et la productrice laitière
affectionne particulièrement cette race
pour sa petite taille
une femme qui travaille souvent se peut
très bien faire vêler les petites vaches
est pas tout au plus le 505 125 kg le
elle dans les plus grosses
donc c'est plus facile à manipuler
comment de vue tantôt la ville que j'ai
appelé cinéma elle est née très
facilement en un claquement de doigts
[Musique]
mais aux yeux de caroline pelletier le
principal attrait de c vhc le lesquels
produisent
il est différent de celui qu'on trouve
généralement sur le marché c'est du lait
à 2 caroline pelletier a commencé à
penser à changer la génétique de son
troupeau pour en produire
après que m il lui a mis la puce à
l'oreille c'est un ami commun qui me
parlait d'une intolérance cas peut-être
le lait de josy serait plus digestible
qui avait pas de problème alors salek
pied vraiment ma curiosité y avait pas
de réaction du tout howlett josé ses
recherches lui ont appris que les vaches
de race josé produisent naturellement
plus de lait à deux queues de l'oea ne
les réguliers le a1 est généralement
produit par les vaches de race austin
est ce qui caractérise le lait à 2 c'est
le type de bêta cazine une protéine
qu'on trouve dans le précieux liquide
elle peut être de type 1 ou à deux selon
le bagage génétique des bovins si
l'animal possède deux allèles identique
du même gène
il est à 2 à 2 ou à 1 1
s'il porte deux allèles différent il est
à 1 à 2 c'est en éliminant des génisses
à 2 à 2 avec du sperme de bovins qui
sont aussi à 2 à 2 qu'on obtient des
animaux qui porte uniquement les gènes à
2 à 2 et qui produisent du lait du même
nom depuis 2003 elle est commercialisée
sous le nom de et to make est vendu en
nouvelle zélande en australie en chine
au royaume-uni ainsi qu'aux états unis
ces fabricants prétendent qu'il serait
plus facile à digérer pour ceux qui ont
des problèmes gastro intestinaux en
consommant du lait régulier à 1
quelques études scientifiques en sont
venus à la même conclusion
mais les sujets testés étaient
intolérants au lactose et non à la bêta
cazine déplore ce spécialiste
peut-être que cette case in à 2 et mieux
digéré que la caséine à 1 mais ça ça
jamais été démontrée et certainement pas
par les études de qui ont été publiés
quel est le rationnel qui explique que
on tolère mieux seul est là parce que
c'est bien beau de voir une différence
que les gens disent je me suis amélioré
mais si on n'arrive pas à comprendre
pourquoi c'est difficile d'être vaincu
le gastro-entérologue pense toutefois
qu'il faut poursuivre les recherches
enfin beaucoup de gens qui peuvent avoir
des symptômes en buvant du lait alors
pourquoi pas exploré des les différents
et qui pourrait pourquoi pas être mieux
digérer mais encore faut-il le prouver
[Musique]
pour caroline pelletier ce qui compte ce
sont les témoignages de ses clients
toutes sortes de personnes de tous âges
viennent me voir et me servent presque
dans leurs bras je sais ce que c'est
très émotif
ils ne peuvent pas consommer notre
produit laitier il descend de sherbrooke
trois-rivières tous les coins du québec
au centre d'insémination artificielle du
québec le siac on a déjà pris le virage
c'est ici qu'on prélève la semence des
taureaux qui est ensuite vendue pour
inséminer les vaches laitières ont
fourni des doses de semence de taureaux
à 2 à 2 aux producteurs laitiers depuis
2015 ont 5 ça décolle train qui demain
de là à dire que c'est fou plus que tout
le monde veut son nom ça c'est sûr que
non mais les gens ils cherchent des
opportunités
si le siècle s'intéresse à cette
nouveauté c'est parce qu'il sent le vent
tourner dalphond avec les marchés qui
sont en compétition avec le lait les
boissons dame en et boissons de soyaux
et tous se savent ça pousse les
producteurs de lait à réagir pour vous
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
propulser marché s'il y avait moins de
l'aic et produits au québec ou au canada
donc on va vendre moins de s'avancer sur
personnellement ça a été une de mes
motivations pour se positionner dans ce
marché là pour indirectement vendre sans
[Musique]
ce représentant du siècle livre
aujourd'hui de la semence à 2 chez un
producteur laitier de saint roch des
aulnaies dans chaudière appalaches
[Musique]
la ferme telle a été quand même un de
mes premiers clients à faire une
sélection génétique à 100% des taureaux
à 2 à 2
on remonte au tout début faisons environ
quatre ans complète ici les taureaux qui
choisit qui sélectionne sont basés sur
l'a21 de la particularité de ce client
c'est 400 vaches sont des austin la race
qui a naturellement le moins de gêne à 2
à 2 pour mener à terme la conversion
génétique de son troupeau gervais
pelletier devra patienter quelques
années
il faut cependant que la tante en vaut
la peine
les sauces avec eux en connaît d'autres
pays qui non utilisés du gazoduc super
taikyu scènes alternatives qu'on peut à
rouelles aucun des deux et mardi là que
commence à quel point les millénium ou
vendus sont plus en plus axé vers des
10es c'est nouveau aussi s'effectuer
qu'à aider aussi à faire la promotion
d'autres éventuellement à quelques
jeunes
[Musique]
pour l'instant seulement 10% des vaches
de la ferme pelras sont certifiés à 2 à
2 de là l'importance de sélectionner
chaque dose de semences fait que j'avais
j'avais un doute aussi un auteur est
intéressante aux montres et vu que c'est
un croisement un peu différent un fils
de fabolous qui était à 2 à 2 dans ses
premiers fils qu'on met en marche et moi
je viens lui présenter des taureaux
gervais aime bien quand même choisir sa
génétique je moi je lui offre certaines
possibilités dans les taureaux qu'on a
quand la situation dans son choix
et j'avais tant deuxième choix deuxième
choix va être pas la rouille
enfin au taureau qui radio 2 que les
peulhs et même profil que le premier va
nous parler
la distribution de lait à 2 n'est pas
encore à l'agenda des grands joueurs de
l'industrie qui considère cela comme un
produit marginal d'hervé pelletier croit
tout de même que ces efforts porteront
fruit le lait biologique qu'à sa
carnation dec sur votre wall un silence
qu'elle soit là aujourd'hui on y croyait
plus jouer mais aujourd'hui on est forcé
quoique consommateurs s'éduquer raison
[Musique]
pour contourner le problème de la
distribution
caroline pelletier a ouvert une
fromagerie où elle vend son lait
ses produits sont distribués dans
quelques marchés publics de la province
et certaines épiceries spécialisées la
demande au début 2019 était inexistante
ou pratiquement alors il fallait faire
naître le produit ici et puis le
positionner de façon à ce que les gens
me demandent et l'a demandé
très forte en ce moment
[Musique]
la production de l'entreprise qui est
encore artisanal passera bientôt de 600
à 1000 bouteilles par semaine
on peut voir ça comme ça produit de
niche directement local proximité c'est
la grosse tendance
on est un démarrage encore mais
vraisemblablement on est un gestion de
croissance
en même temps c'est notre défi de cette
année
au canada on compte seulement une
poignée de producteurs de lait certifié
à deux mais c'est une tendance à
surveiller dans le monde agroalimentaire